هذا وتوعد رئيس جهاز المساعده الاسرائيليه
ديفيد برنيع بتصفيه كل من كانت له علاقه
بما سبها مذبحه السابع من اكتوبر في غلاف
غزه وجاء تهديده خلال كلمه القاها في
جنازه الرئيس الاسبق للمصدف زمير مستذكرا
السياسه التي نفذها زمير بملاحقه وتصفيه
من كانت له علاقه بعمليه قتل الرياضيين
الاسرائيليين في ميونخ بالمانيا قبل نحو
50 عاما قائلا انه سيحذف
حذوه ي اليوم ايضا نحن في ذروه حرب
والموساد اليوم وكما كان قبل 50 عاما ملزم
بتصفيه الحساب مع القتله الذين غزوا غلاف
غزه في السابع من اكتوبر ومع المخططين
ومرسل ايهم وهذا سيستغرق وقتا كما استغرق
بعد المذبحه في ميونخ لكن ايادينا ستصل
اليهم في كل مكان يوجدون فيه ولتعلم كل ام
عربيه انه اذا كان ابنها قد شارك بشكل
مباشر او غير مباشر في منحه السابع من
اكتوبر فان دمه
مهدور